sein ich bin ich bin kari du bist du
bist janus sie es ist
er ist 1 meter 75 groß sie ist verwirrt
wir sind wir sind in der uni ihr seid
ihr seid sportlich sie sind sie sind gut
drauf haben
ich habe ich habe urlaub
du hast du hast kraft er sie es hat
janosch hat hunger
[Gelächter]
sie hat schluckauf
wir haben also ein hase kommt wir haben
keine zeit auge
ihr habt ihr habt langeweile
sie haben und der hase sagt plumps sie
haben keinen humor gehen
ich gehe ich gehe in die bibliothek du
gehst
warum gehst du immer hinter mir her er
sie oder es geht
janosch geht aufs klo
sie geht mir auf die nerven ich kari
kari kari
wir gehen wir gehen weg geht
ihr geht auf mich zu sie gehen
sie gehen immer zusammen
bei unserem dreh haben wir so viel spaß
dass wir glatt die abmoderation
vergessen haben
aber gott sei dank ist uns dass hier am
strand noch eingefallen
im deutschen gibt es 200 unregelmäßige
verben und die kommunikation von diesen
werben müsst ihr alle individuellen
lernen heute habt ihr die drei oder drei
der häufigsten unregelmäßigen verben
gehört und wenn ihr lust habt jetzt noch
mehr zu lernen
dann guckt euch unbedingt mal unsere app
sieht lang an
in zielen könnt ihr mit interaktiven
videos lernen und unter anderem könnt
ihr dabei unregelmäßige verben lernen
aber auch eure aussprache trainieren und
es gibt einen vokabeltrainer der euch an
in regelmäßigen abständen an eure neuen
vokabeln erinnert probiert das ganze mal
aus wir freuen uns auf eure kommentare
danke fürs zuschauen und tschüss bis zur
nächsten woche
liebe grüße aus santa barbara